it's considered to be the most stable
country in central america
famous for its beautiful beaches and
environmental protection
but in the past years poverty and
unemployment have been on the rise
the pandemic had a devastating impact on
the vital tourism sector
something that most people are hoping a
new president will be able to reverse
the next president should change
everything because we are very poor
there's nothing here so i hope that from
here on in whoever wins fights for this
country because we're costa ricans we
have to
voters will elect a new president this
sunday in what many say is the most
polarized campaign in years
they'll be choosing between former
center-left president jose maria
figueres who is promising to revive the
economy protect minority rights and the
environment
we are going to focus on the issues that
are most important and for us of course
the main one is the revival of the
economy and the creation of job
opportunities in this country
he faces conservative rodrigo chavez a
former world bank employee who promises
to fight corruption and has based his
campaign on attacking traditional
politics in the country he's promising
to clean the house
we have a 75 year party that only now
talks about corruption it took them so
long to realize that corruption is the
worst because of stealing from the
people both candidates are surrounded in
controversy former president figeres
faced accusations of corruption while he
was in office and chavez was accused of
sexual harassment while working at the
world bank
the accusations of corruption against
his party are real and all these years
we've seen mayors and other politicians
involved in scandals with chavez there
was an investigation by the world bank
and he had to resign to prevent
sanctions from the world bank
both candidates deny the allegations
many voters here think the candidates on
offer are the worst choice they could
have and the hope is that whoever wins
will be able to bring back economic
growth
teresa